Problem 28.
Which equation best represents
the part of
the graph shown below?
So we have a bunch of
equations here.
Let's see.
This one is just a linear
equation, so this is just some
number times x.
So that graph in general would
be a straight line.
This one and this one
are straight lines.
This one would be a straight
line with a positive slope,
maybe look something
like that.
This choice C right here would
be a straight line with a
negative slope, like that.
They would both go through the
origin, because they don't
have any y-intercept
right there.
So neither of these
are the answer.
So let's look at these two--
I guess we could call them
quadratics.
So here we have 1.75x squared.
So the graph of x squared--
let me do it in a better
color-- the graph of x squared
looks like this.
It's a parabola.
You've seen that before.
And they're drawing it in the
first quadrant right there,
and that looks about right.
And you're like, hey, but
what about the 1.75?
Well, that's just a
scaling factor.
If you throw a larger number
there, it'll curve up a little
bit faster.
If you throw a smaller number
there, it'll curve up a little
bit slower.
But the general idea is that
they all have the general
shape of a parabola.
So this one looks pretty good.
It's an upward opening
parabola.
It's kind of an upright U.
So this looks like a pretty
good solution.
If we were to draw the whole
graph, it would continue on
this side like that.
Then choice D, it's just like
choice B, except they have a
minus here.
And the reason why I know that's
not going to work is
that the graph of minus x
squared, or minus anything
times x squared is going
to look like this.
It's going to be downward
opening.
So this is the graph of minus x
squared, the graph of minus
1.75x squared, might
open up or go down
a little bit faster.
So it's going to have the
same general shape.
So we know that this is also
not the right answer.
So our choice is B.
Next question.
29.
Lisa typed a 1,000-word essay
at the average rate of 20
words per minute.
If she started typing at 6:20
PM and did not take any
breaks, at what time did Lisa
finish typing the essay?
So she had a 1,000-word essay
and she was typing at 20 words
per minute.
So let me write that down.
So she had 1,000 words
and she's typing at
20 words per minute.
So if you're writing 1,000 words
and you're doing 20 per
minute, how many minutes
is it going to take?
Well, what's 1,000
divided by 20?
You could do this
in your head.
You say 100 divided
by 20 is 5.
1,000 is 10 hundreds.
So it's going to be 50.
But if you don't want to do it
in your head, you can just say
20 goes into 1,000-- 20 goes
into 10 zero times.
20 goes into 100 five times.
5 times 20 is 100, and then
you bring down the 0.
20 goes into 0 zero times, and
then 0 times 20 is 0, and then
you are done.
20 goes into 1,000
fifty times.
Or you could say 2 goes
into 100 five times.
All the same thing.
Just 20-- and then--
sorry, 50.
Want to be careful.
So it'll take her 50 minutes,
and actually
the units work out.
You have words divided by words
per minute, or that's
the same thing as words times
minutes per word.
They cancel out, and you
end up with 50 minutes.
If that confuses you, don't
worry about it too much.
The intuition is what's
important.
You had a 1,000-word essay, you
did 20 words per minute.
So it was going to take
you 50 minutes.
50 minutes times 20 words
per minute is
equal to 1,000 words.
So you're going to
have 50 minutes.
So she starts at 6:20 PM.
So at 7:00 PM, she's worked
for 40 minutes.
Because there's 60 minutes
in an hour.
But she works for 50
minutes, so she
does another 10 minutes.
So that gets her to 7:10.
So the choice is D.
Problem 30.
What does-- let me
do it in red.
What does x to the fifth equal
when x is equal to minus 2?
So it's minus 2 times minus 2
times minus 2 times minus 2
times minus 2.
Now we can just multiply
it all out.
Let's just do that,
just for fun.
Minus 2 times minus
2 is positive 4.
Then positive 4 times
minus 2 is minus 8.
Minus 8 times minus
2 is positive 16.
Positive 16 times minus
2 is minus 32.
So our answer is A.
Now, if you wanted to do that
really fast, you might
recognize, well, 2 to
the fifth is 32.
So it's either going to be that
choice or that choice.
And then we have
a odd exponent.
So we're going to be multiplying
a negative times
itself an even time, and
then one more negative.
So you're going to get
a negative number.
When you have an odd exponent,
you're going to
end up with a negative.
You have an even exponent,
you'll end up with a positive.
So that would have been the fast
way to do it, but even if
you didn't do that, you could
have just multiplied it
straight out like we just did.
And just remember a negative
times a negative is a
positive, and then a
positive times the
negative is a negative.
It's minus 32.
31.
The graph below compares the
weight of an object on Earth
to its weight on the Moon.
Interesting.
An object's weight on the Moon,
OK, so this is the Moon
weight, this is the
Earth weight.
So something that-- let's say--
well, I actually do
weigh 150 pounds.
So I weigh 150 pounds on Earth,
and according to this
chart, I would weigh 25
pounds on the Moon.
Or I would weigh essentially
1/6 my weight
that I am on Earth.
What is it asking me?
What is the approximate weight
on the Moon of an astronaut
who weighs 120 pounds
on Earth?
Well, I just said, essentially
this thing is just taking 1/6.
You can look at any point.
When you weigh 10 pounds on
the Moon, you're weighing
roughly 60 pounds on Earth,
or vice versa.
So you just take 1/6,
or we could actually
just look at the chart.
120 pounds-- so if we go
halfway, that's about 125,
between 100 and 150.
120 pounds would
be right there.
You go up the graph,
just like that.
And you go there, and it looks
like 18 or 19 pounds.
And they say, what is the
approximate weight?
So the closest thing we are
here, let's see, the
choice of 15 and 20.
We're definitely closer to
20 than we are to 15.
So I will go with
20 right here.
And you know, if we really
wanted to look at it, this is
actually the point that we
should have looked at, this
point right here would
have been 120 pounds.
But you just approximate where
120 is, you read the graph,
you say, oh, it's closer
to 20 than any
of these other choices.
So that'll be our answer.